you can't post the same picture on
Twitter and Instagram and Linkedin and
think you're going to get the same
result people are in a different mindset
also those platforms work differently
they have different ways to format
pictures different lengths of creative
this is one masterful game of
communication the reason we know the
people that we know in history whether
Muhammad Ali or Gandhi is because they
were great Communications hackers above
and beyond what they were actually doing
for a living everybody here now has the
luxury of having the internet be the
platform that they can communicate on
yet we have bum rushed into a game of
hacking or looking for shortcuts or the
thing that will break through versus
becoming Craftsmen and crafts women on
these platforms